bella a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo video io pago quest'uomo per fare
un sacco di cose oltre che montarmi
video volevo dirvi che smarcato schiavo
io io volevo dirvi che sono stato da
poco insieme anche giampiero nella live
di marco merlino che ha fatto qualche
giorno fa la 24 ore marco mi ha
ingaggiato per tagliarli la barba visto
che io sono un esperto di non barbe io
glie l'ho tolta e in questo video
abbiamo anzi ha messo insieme le clip
meglio 52 per fare i tuoi video e niente
ciao vivono il video poi un applauso lo
verso
ma parliamo delle prime impressioni più
o meno la prima impressione che ho avuto
io e che sapevo che impazzano
però poi passò una barba fatti
senso esagera non so perché ero teso
reso vero saggio esagerato però penso
che tu sia l'unica persona che è stato
detto anche in un video che abbiamo
registrato che poi uscirà se l'unica
persona che mi ha insegnato ad essere
davvero che devi essere veramente te
stesso con gli altri portali in modo
fondamentale tu mi ha insegnato questa
cosa
nessuno perché tu non sei come nei video
si permette anche un pelo peggio nella
vita
insomma quindi sono molto contento di
questo siamo pieni di vibo la gente
questo me lo chiede però chiedono in
tanti
lui sta in dividere si trattiene però
dato è molto vero comunque troviamo
sempre nuovi modi per tradurre almeno
quello che lo stand trattenimento per le
persone alla fine il confine artista e
può esser cercare di tradursi nel modo
migliore slash perciò non può che io
direi questo di farlo alzato se ti siedi
qui riguarda la sua certo ma vendiamo e
belle e buone tiberiana
una cosa sola io non sono rispetto né
tagliata barba quindi dammi solo un di
vita per lei il pulsante non è il potere
no fa malissimo se sbaglia tanto non c'è
problema allora no no sì sì e di no che
vede detto momento però va bene dai
voler avere un problema
taglieremo i governi il nuovo questa
volta no questa è la maratona di molto
mourinho per subito questo box
marco massetti pato quindi un po della
tua parte l'astio dell'as km numerica ma
questa volta non andrebbe l'efficienza
non andrà mai a vecchi ricordi cosa
abbiamo fatto anche l'ultima volta
insieme dove chi ha arrecato sofferenza
era molto peggio
quello era quando non ti abbiamo già
fatto io ho ancora da completare del
pezzo ma si può far vedere nato come
successo l'ultimo the stone west lezione
più approdo questo mai inondarsi di cera
bollente trasparenza perché se
trasparente utile che hanno ancora
caldissima quindi al momento dove guarda
se devo rivolgere che ammiro di oliva
dove siamo a due
va bene allora ragazzi iniziamo con
questa questa cosa
[Musica]
io non posso anche se faccio prima parte
dalla strada verso il basso poi dopo mi
riprendo la sottostima gli faccio prima
tutto verso l'alto e quello
sappiate allora che cominciò ragazzi di
quando si vede via lasciata al ghana
brutto stato dato una versione stato
molto diplomatico nella ragazza da
queste questioni 43 ti rimane che ormai
di fiducia barra capito preparati oggi è
una rinomata è un pollice è un pollice
l'esperimento questa era così
abbracciarti tutto il tempo che sono non
l'ha presa della cosa peggiore da
vicentin amicizia va bene ragazzi ma non
mi senti faccio male altro canto lo
spiega giovanni 36 segnando un bambino
[Musica]
adesso chiara garcia della in mare di
fare questa cosa mi sento freddo che
altri fratelli incredibile sembrate
padre figlio
sembrate gesù che nove figli a fare
qualcosa di
non avrebbero il senato è riuscito mi
sono tagliato con il costruita massimo
faccio certamente vero dramma fa sempre
molto conosciuto la sua volta sopra mi
scusi mai dire sto scherzando
[Musica]
dicono sei nazisti passo rivedere
[Applauso]
secondo me quei film ti può cambiare la
vita con un click tornati perché vivano
ciccioni che hanno questa esperienza qui
ho detto più avere un altro caso del
server ma da quanto ci nega che l'ultima
volta parla d'altro
[Musica]
ma lasciateli bolelli
facciamole poter inquadrare il primo
piano questa
[Musica]
come richiedono le donazioni ma con il
suo figlio alessandro di trapianto però
vede tantissimo e non certo di arrivo va
bene allora allora giusto in bagno da
noi classi abbiamo un sacco di cose non
sembrarlo e con la barba queste cose le
vedo molto avvantaggiate logisticamente
però non cercava questo oggi eccomi qua
marco e remo la brava tavolo del g20
crescera complimenti ma soprattutto
questo si vede un livello di qualità
arma per non dire assente su tweet
chiuse di collegamento meno allora io
sono
soddisfatto se vogliamo concludere
questa cosa del risultato ha pensato
abbiamo di giocare sino dico pensavo di
dover lasciare un'impronta maggiore come
judy così una signora cosa fare anche
tua figlia non sarebbe uguale ce lo
possiamo più provarci ma è niente per il
resto sono sono molto contento alla fine
del primo tempo l'unica roberto così
dire palla non parliamo di widget
io so voi ragazzi sapete quanto lui ci
ha messo la pulce ma io vi assicuro che
per chi amico di marco vanno a credere
in questa stanza e molte persone che non
sono qua noi sappiamo avendo vissuto
marchi persona quanto lui ci ha messo a
fare qui ci maledizione oggi io sono qua
oltre che si trova vigili sono qua con
il suo amico e oggi io pittorico sono
molto molto orgoglioso di te per quello
che hai fatto per come sta strutturando
la cosa e ho visto finalmente un marco
deciso spacca tutto però
è arrivata stanca bellissimo ha detto
quest'anno per ad oggi è veramente male
l'ultimo disperato sono gravissimi e tu
hai paura di questa forza secondo quello
non ne ho mai un perfetto
potete prendervi un bicchiere così
mettiamo la mia barba da la scena viene
qua non picchiare tipo diverso per le
ricche cina ci siamo quindi valutati e
salutiamo intanto voglio ringraziare il
mio amico lorenzo e ha fatto l'in
fattibile è stato qui con noi non solo
il cambiamento editrice ma anche
corporeo grazie per essere nudo quando
vuoi perché amiamo tutti voi almeno le
abitudini alla barba chissà
[Musica]